there was an article written yesterday
up no Blair I think Blair white actually
wrote it for the post-millennial yeah I
have it I got it is it is Blair white it
says is the white guy of the way the
white he's the people it is literally a
white guy he's the white man so this is
Pete blue judge isn't gay enough for
queer activist they're not gonna be
happy until there is there's a disabled
non-binary you know trans trans racial
neurodivergent something like other kin
like just know like know this guy like
who knows what his politics are I don't
know but the fact that we have somebody
the openly gay running for mayor of
running forward from there well you is
there running for president this is this
is the problem and and with the crazy
thing to me is that why it why it starts
so often in the LGBT communities is
strange to me but it does you know it is
pervasive it does extend outside of that
the general left Pete Budaj edge is
literally married it to a man it is a
huge stride for gay rights to see him as
he's currently arguably the front-runner
now Bernie Sanders has the popular vote
Budaj edge right now in the Democratic
primaries has more delegates so far with
has only been to two is been at one
caucus in one primary Buddha judge could
very well win the Democratic nomination
and no one on the right
Trump or anyone actually there's been a
couple people but for the most part
conservatives aren't saying like he's
disqualified he's gay married no it's
like they're talking about his politics
it's the left that's coming after him
for not being of the right cultural
structure or whatever there was only
that one lady in Iowa who was know
someone someone someone said it may have
been like Rush Limbaugh
I don't know that that America is in
that dream America isn't ready to see a
gay man kisses husband you know in the
White House or something like that but
this is it is absolutely insane that
we're in a place so Blair white writes
this article Pete bridges isn't gay
enough for queer activists let me let me
read a little bit of this you know let
me read
she Blair White's in a sane world the
LGBTQ community and its allies would be
ecstatic that a gay presidential
candidate would be receiving not only
national attention but real traction
with a surging campaign a few years ago
before the woke cult takeover here here
Blair this would have signified a huge
step forward for acceptance however to
the surprise of some at Pete Buddha
judges facing backlash from insatiable
queer activists who cite his white
audience and a lack of concerns for the
broader LGBT community it's important to
note this broader LGBT community is
being expanded and stretched daily even
most LGBT people can't keep up and as we
know right now miss Arielle Scarcella is
being excised from that LGBT community
because you dare speak up and defend
yourself in your community so a little
bit more I really want to this is this
is this is this Pete Buddha judge thing
I think is the best example of what the
problem is on the left this is a sign of
victory and they refuse and it is not
the Conservatives complaining about
people to judge his orientation it's the
left mind numbing a little bit more from
Blair she writes while speaking the San
Francisco's national LGBTQ Center for
the Arts
moody judge was protested by a group
called queers against Pete who began
chanting boot edge edge a degrading
reference to bootie judge as a boot
licker but that's literally what his
fans cheer right his fans chant boot
edge whatever she says this is a common
irrational attack by radical activists
against minorities who dare disagree
with them on any level one of the
protesters spoke to the Guardian stated
it's hard to enjoy or appreciate booty
judges status as a gay candidate because
he speaks to a predominantly white
upper-class audience other protesters
cited Budaj edge refusal to boycott
chick-fil-a oh jeez it's a chicken
sandwich man you know what I saw before
he even started running I was seeing
tweets from activists talking about how
he had never made a big enough deal
about him going to pride I was like oh
so that's how it's gonna be not good
enough not good enough that's crazy
a little bit more of this an open
statement from queers against Pete
Reid's some have touted former South
Bend mayor Pete Buda judges openly gay
identity as proof of progress in her
politics
however the
gay is not enough to earn the support of
the LGBTQIA communities we cannot in
good conscience allow mayor Pete to
become the nominee without demanding
that he addressed the needs and concerns
of the broader lesbian gay bisexual
transgender queer intersex and asexual
community's Blair says all right here's
the part where I give up objectivity and
insert my opinion this is ridiculous as
a Republican I will not be voting for
Buddha judge however even I can
acknowledge the positive step forward in
terms of culture that he represents a
few years ago the idea of a gay
candidate having any chance of becoming
president whatsoever would have been
laughable at best despite our political
differences I think it's awesome
representation for the community but of
course you can never appease the woke
mob you can never be gay enough and you
can never be progressive enough the
goalposts will always be moved towards
further radicalism and anyone who
doesn't instantly move with it will be
left behind and cancelled as far as I
can see Buddha judges policies land
firmly in the progressive Lane yet still
don't meet the standard of those who see
white gay men in the same way they see
other privileged demographics the
possibility of the first gay president
and his husband living in the white
house means nothing to the rabid mob
only time will tell if the radical or
moderate voices will rise the top and
determine Buddha did his fate alright
man I gotta say it again I really really
do a few years ago or maybe like ten
years ago Oh or oh no no no let's go
back to Brock Obama's first camp first
term he was opposed to gay marriage in
the last Democratic president four years
ago started his first term in opposition
to gay marriage after he leaves Pete
Buddha judge a gay married man is up on
the debate stage leading the pack
arguably yeah I think Bernie Sanders is
the front-runner it's fair to say but
Budaj edge is is is quickly rising he's
got the delegate count right now they're
not projecting him to win it's a huge
deal where where where where have we
gone that there's no objection at all
from conservatives Trump's not dragging
him forward at all and it's the left
dragging him for it the left is part of
protesting his events it's almost like
they're the the
actual homophobic 'its and what's crazy
about this event I don't know if you saw
this story but when when these queer
activists started protesting Pete Buddha
judge a Buddha judge supporter started
yelling at them that they were
homophobes and then this argument broke
out between the two groups where they
were accusing each other of being
homophobic to me that's just such a
purity test there's there's no answer to
see those two factions arguing over that
give me a break so how do we how do we
how do we actually get progress for the
LGBT community when they're protesting
themselves in their successes I know
you're leaving done you gave up I gave
up and I tried for five years I've tried
five years since 2013 2014 if when
Barack Obama ran the black community
protested protested Barack Obama saying
he isn't black enough you know his mom
was white or whatever that would be
insane it was it was it was it was a
great moment for civil rights that
Barack Obama could become president and
to me as a millennial it didn't for me I
was kind of confused when they were like
I remember older people telling me how I
was a big deal if you ought to
understand is the first you know
non-white is the first black president
and I was like does that mean he's gonna
be a good president like I didn't
understand no yeah and and but it was
actually a friend of mine who was black
who first asked me that's like do you
think that'll make him good president I
was like I don't know I grew up in a
time where we were we were supposed to
not care about you know that the we're
worried about the content of someone's
character now it's it's it's it's just
nuts it's just nuts Barack Obama did a
lot of good things a lot of bad things
but you know for what it's worth in our
society it was a big deal they became
president but now it's Buddha judges
it's the LGBT community or whatever it's
supposed to be now I have no idea yeah
resisting him being president what's
what do they want do they want Trump I
think that if black people had responded
to a bomb of the way that gay people are
responding the Buddha judge that that
would have fractured the Democratic
Party at that time like its fracturing
the Democratic Party today a factory now
I think it would have been the same
thing I think that's what we're saying I
don't know why you know I'm both
physically and mentally tired it's it
because no matter how many
I've tried saying like hey this is a bad
idea and then sure enough a week later
like they flop on their face because was
a bad idea
this never stops and I've been telling
them to shut up not shut up but I've
been telling them that what they're
saying has you know is making us look
like idiots for the last five years and
now the rate of acceptance is down so if
you if you leave the left like what does
that really mean where do you go what do
you do what changes right
I just mean sticking by my morals and
not being associated with those people
for me yeah yeah it when you're already
not caving yeah but now I'm not speaking
out even more I think I guess it I guess
the easiest way to put it from my
perspective is you've put your foot down
yeah I'm sad I mean yeah you
they've towed the line this whole
they've crossed the line the whole time
and I just let it have let them do it
and I never had enough I think one of
the easiest ways to look at how what you
are doing in leaving because of things
like this the ramifications streams like
this yeah we're having a conversation
the title is liberal youtuber announcing
she's leaving the left so they're gonna
claim it's propaganda they're gonna
accuse you of being a far-right
conservative racist or whatever they're
gonna call you everything in the book
she just wants people to validate her
remember Laci Laci green when she oh
when she did the red pill video and then
they were like she's alright now that's
she's like a huge famous feminist right
didn't matter that she dared entertain
other opinions they had to smear her
alright yeah so they'll come for you in
two seconds there they're already coming
okay they're already calling her at Turf
which is so rude considering that she
has absolutely nothing against trans
people she actually genuinely seems to
not like the way that they're being used
but I support the wrong cut we came up
with the hashtag wrong kind of trans
yeah I think you're gonna get banned
from YouTube no no no Twitter or
anything like that no no no because I
respect people's pronouns and I I do
think dysphoria is a real thing but I
think you're crossing the line when
you're saying that biological sex isn't
real and all these you know so so
actually this is this is this is really
great we've come to a point where first
you had people like you know Dave Rubin
you know Dave yeah he's gay married
and he was like I'm leaving the left and
he leaves the left and now you're
someone who actually says I respect
pronouns
I respect the community you talk about
you know social you know nurture and
like a lot of things that are typically
associated with more with the
intersectional feminists right and even
you now are been being like I'm out
overnight
these people are nuts there's no same
conversation to be had yeah somebody
somebody just direct message me so
you're officially a hashtag walk away I
guess but but I think I think that's
about joining the Republicans
yeah I'm not joining the Republicans I'm
just joint I'm just not with them I
think I'm wrong I think I'm wrong I
think walk away is just leaving the
Democratic Party for me I don't even
know if that's true with me I do but I
do disagree with a lot of what the
Democrats have been and how they've been
treating you know well those guys
outside of politics cuz I you know Pete
Moody judge you probably not feels we're
familiar with but based on how they
respond to him neither how would want to
be associated with them yeah yeah
besides anybody that they're so in their
own hive mentality like a hive mind
mentality right now they they have no I
genuinely think these people don't think
they're doing anything wrong I think
they think they are I don't think they
think Rosa Parks of their generation I
know I really do I think that they think
that I think that they think we're gonna
we're putting trans we're putting the
the most you know marginalized person
possible in the front seat and that's
the way to do it and that's good to
listen to minority voices but don't you
know crap on ones that you know that
better that are slowly coming up like
Pete like Blair like me like we're
finally being heard but we're not
progressive enough for these were the
wrong kind of LGBT the wrong kind of
trans the wrong kind of gay where to God
2020 this year this election come
November it's going to be so much like
campaign ads from minorities that are
pro Trump LGBT pro-trump immigrants for
Trump it would be smart be smart that
would be very sunny but for him doing
it's like walk away is a gay man put on
a manga hat yeah it's people leaving the
left it's like III think Trump is gonna
form this massive coalition and he's
supposed to be this
awful evil orange man and all these
things but it's like for all his faults
you know what I'll give this example
there they're targeting Peabody judge
because he isn't gay enough when Donald
Trump was called out for insulting women
things you've just recently criticized
him for his response was yeah well you
know what this country is too
politically correct and everyone sort of
clapping and cheering he refused to
apologize he's right like everybody
everybody draws their line in a
different place you know right and and
my line is for sure for sure I can
absolutely respect that I agree and
here's the thing though you're given the
choice between the lunatic left and a
guy who's just mean yeah Trump Trump is
an entertainer and as much as my like I
don't think his behavior is the most
important thing for the presidential
office but I do think it is important
but look what the alternative is like I
actually think Peter Budaj is a pretty
alright dude I've watched him to mate
I've seen what I say
the problem is it's kind of just a
generic you know what's that what did
they say he's he learned how to be
president by watching tapes of Obama no
no apparently he is they're protesting
him but nobody else has our first always
like a gray blob but but but I think
he's kind of an all right dude I just
don't know if he's got enough of that
x-factor to be President right yeah yeah
he's very you know but but he's a cool
dude I think it's insane oh they're
coming after him like this and so now we
have the politically homeless liberals
like I